A final consequence of Handel's law that we will
discuss, is the law of diminishing returns. Let's say
that we had an original processor, which we will
call GEN1 in which our execution time can roughly
be divided into a purple phase and a blue
phase each of them takes about half the execution
time. Let's say that in the generation 2 processor
we decided to speed up the blue phase by factor
of two. What we got now is that the purple part is not affected and the
blue part is now half as long. The orbital speed up of the GEN2 processor over
GEN1 is equal to one over half is not enhanced. Half is speed up by a
factor of two and we get the the speed-up of 133, which is a sizeable speed-up.
Now let's say that we have a generation three
processor, where we again get the blue part and speed
it up by a factor of two, relative to
the GEN2 processors. Now we have that the purple part
is still the same, and the blue part is half of what it was. The speed up of the
GEN3 processor over a GEN2 processor is 1 over and
now we have to be careful. The unaffected part is
now 2 3rds of the execution time. The
affected part is only one third and that part
is still affected by a factor of 2, so the overall speed up is 1.2 over GEN2.
If we keep improving the blue part over
the generations, eventually we will get to almost no
speed up. Why? Because we are improving what
amounts to less and less of the execution time.
Furthermore, usually it is the case that improving
something initially is not very hard, but after you
exhaust the easy methods for improvement, it becomes very,
very difficult to get new speed ups on a
thing that has been already enhanced hugely. So eventually,
the solutions that will improve the purple part will
be cheaper than the solutions that further improve the
blue part just because all of the easy stuff
on improving the blue part we have already done.
So not only do we get lower speed ups
by improving the blue part, it's actually becoming more
difficult to do so. This is sort of a
lesson to computer architects to not go overboard improving
the same thing, because the things they have already
improved are now a smaller percentage of the new
execution time, and we need to reassess what is
now the dominant part in the execution time. In other words, once you
have applied one improvement, you need to reconsider what is now the new
dominant part in the execution time.
And definitely, when applying Handel's law, we
need to consider what is now the fraction enhanced, and the fraction unenhanced.